land which couple would you like to save
it untitled it on totally honest neither
of these couples should be in this
position it's very difficult because one
I want to judge from my heart the other
I have to judge with my brain and my
brain says I've got to save right I'm
sure we are so sad to see you go missing
an icon an icon what is your time meant
here in the ballroom I'm sorry what is
your time meant here in the ballroom oh
I've had a great time I mean it was I'm
still in the beginning stages right
getting used to the stage and all that
stuff but it was fun it was so much fun
so glad you were here because you got to
educate this man right here on some
other legends like a ritha Franklin you
know I mean we are shocked I was born in
94 so let's take a pump the brakes I was
raised in Utah pump the brake I got a
good of Reason know he taught me a lot
of things in fact I never would have
learned the foxtrot nor the ChaCha
so you sought me and I'm very happy to
say that he's an excellent teacher Oh
coach I should say not teacher right the
best moment of this entire episode was
tonight when was that Lander said lense
what's telling you to close your legs
and you thought he said spread your legs
and it was did he really
I really because you can't really hear
when we were standing so I was like oh
my god I hope he didn't say that cuz my
mommy always said to say something
different if you do something different
but he was wonderful they all the judges
were really cool you know an icon it has
been an honor to have you here and we'll
see you on the next thing was I hope so
[Music]
[Applause]